le multivers
c'est la vie ou la mort
vous pourriez utiliser un vengeur
il y a d'autres vendeurs nous vous
remettrons sur la lunch box
le destin du multivers
dépend de nous
pas de pression alors
dr étrange dans le multivers de la folie
billets en vente ce mercredi que faire
tu connais le multivers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous devrions lui dire la vérité
attention stephen
ce chemin exige un lourd tribut
j'ai fait ce que je devais faire
[Applaudissements]
pour protéger notre monde les
choses sont juste devenues incontrôlables
[Musique]
tu casses  les règles
et devenir un héros
ça ne semble pas juste
super
toi